also wenn du hast nächste mal in eine
echte langweiligen klasse setzt schon
kam die augen aufhalten kann
egal was ist das was ist dass man gibt
es mal die gesichter von albträumen was
soll das die leute herzlich kommen wie
auf einem kanal fertig ist
wahrscheinlich sebastian warum hast du
uns heute wieder auf diesem kanal
eingeladen was gibt es heute zu sehen
die antwort ist relativ einfach ich habe
einen youtube kanal gefunden der
dringend gestoppt werden muss ja das
eigentlich ganz gute beschreibung
beziehungsweise leute ich will für
seinen den apfel ich nicht ganz alleine
gefunden sondern mit eurer hilfe
tatsächlich und zwar hat die zuschauer
in kimberley de mir gesagt der kanal 123
go auf youtube das meiste von denen es
einfach concerto nötig mehr kann ich
dazu eigentlich nicht sagen ich hab
jetzt ein zwei videos von den angeschaut
und ich muss sagen kimberly das recht
irgendetwas stimmt mit diesem kanal
nicht also wie gesagt leute haben wenn
sie das heute video dreht heißt 123 go
germany
das liegt daran also dass in germany
namen heißt die daran dass es ein
eigentlich amerikanischer kanal ist also
die gesamten videoaufnahmen die die in
den videos verwenden sind von dem
amerikanischen kanal und die haben
einfach irgendwelche deutschsprachiger
genommen und haben wir den kanal
übersetzen lassen also die videos
einfach nach sprechen lassen dann senden
die jetzt noch mal quasi für deutschland
raus eins von diesen kann ist es seltsam
videos heißt sieben unverschämt witzige
schul streiche einfacher prank für den
schulalltag und es ist auch so dass der
kanal macht so streiche cranks kennst du
das noch aus der grundschule
damit kann man auch heute noch eine
menge spaß haben nimmt ein kleines stück
plate und schneiders mit einem
teppichmesser zu einem quadrat also ein
video wie seit den schuhtrend der erste
bank ist dass sie hubba bubba mit roter
knete austauscht und dann ist jemand
diese rote knete und die stelle ist dann
immer so dana also die stelle in franken
also da wieder aussehen würde
und jetzt hat sie gerade quasi irgend so
eine freundin von ihr knete gegeben zum
essen jetzt geht durch diese nächste
szene die ja was ist das
schon was mir sagt junge warum in
welcher art und weise trägt das
irgendwie zur qualität dieses videos bei
dass ihr dieses gesicht aus einem
abstand von fackeln zehn zentimetern
zeigt okay war so wissen doch keiner
sehen
das war schon nicht so schön anzusehen
leute gerade eben aber gehen wir jetzt
über zu einem video wo einem wirklich
die haare zu berge stehen und zwar das
video peinliche momente die wir alle
schon erlebt haben lustige und peinliche
situationen das video hat zwar 15.000
likes was ziemlich gut ist und 16
millionen aufrufe hat auf diese 14.000
likes aber auch 4600 discs warum
schmeißt die jetzt die tablette ich die
gegend sorry aber ganz kurz so achtet
mal wie ihre füße okay ich gebe mal
close up so die ist nicht gestolpert
die ist nicht mal ansatzweise gestolpert
die setzt einfach ganz normal einen fuß
vor den anderen setzt einfluss denn oben
auf diesen bürgersteig drauf und auf
einmal keine ahnung blonde random
darstellerinnen punkt access top working
und sie schmeiße tablett durch die
gegend wo ist das ein moment den wir
alles schon erlebt haben nein 123 go
german das nicht momente die wir erleben
bei wissen normale menschen bei denen
nicht einfach mal mitten im alltag so
das gehirn ein kurzschluss hatte man
alles von sich weist der bordstein war
schon die ganze zeit da und sorry aber
du bist auch nicht nur den bordstein
gestolpert du bist ganz normal
weitergelaufen und hast dann einfach
gedacht es wäre lustig für ein video so
alle sachen wegzuschmeißen
peinliche momente wir alle erlebt haben
was ist das für ein video
sorry aber was ist das für ein video
entschuldigung also ich stehe so zwei
menschen ok und dann ist er rechts noch
so eine person ich werde nicht kleine
leute schreiben aber dies halb so groß
wie alle anderen und mitten im gespräch
peinliche momente die wir alle schon
erlebt habe die diskutiert so auf einmal
war zudem eine faust in die eier und auf
den typen aus
peinliche momente die wir alles hinein
aber nochmal also das ist kein pallium
mit dem wir alle erlebt haben das ist
kein normales verhalten okay ich meinen
euch natürlich nein klar wir haben es
alles schon erlebt man unterhält sich
zum freund
egal was geht er cool ist wieder da bist
auf sich außer sind ausgenommen
du hast mich bekleckert welcher
geisteskranke mensch denkt sich das aus
wird irgendein weißen fleck auf ihren
blauen oberteil ok alles klar was macht
sie dann als nächstes so ihr habt einen
weißen fleck ungeklärten ursprungs auf
euren klamotten oder sonstwo oder
allgemein flecken egal flecken
auftauchen
das erste was künftiger mensch macht ist
dass ich erst mal ein finger rein
stecken und es in den mund nehmen oral
konsumieren die substanz ihr wisst nicht
was es könnte gift sein okay jetzt kann
alles mögliche sein erstmal mund nimmt
natürlich vernünftig und dann natürlich
leute peinlicher moment den wir alle
schon erlebt haben lag derweil ihr
natürlich geist kommt um seit erst mal
ab was auf ihrem t shirt ist und dann
dann ist das löwen welcher kranke mensch
denkt sich so etwas aus so was passiert
doch nicht im echten leben als ob man da
sitzt auch wenn ich nein es ist okay
wenn ich ein eis essen dann merke ich
doch ob ich mir das alles wie ein
dummkopf auf mein t shirt drauf hacke
oder nicht ja das merkt man doch und
erst recht mehr aktiv
aber auf mich drauf scheißt okay sorry
für die direkt ausdrucksweise leute aber
es ist so ok alles da wir also schauen
wir ein mädchen was eine freundin sucht
sich mit einer freundin verabredet hat
und aus irgendeinem grund schreibt seine
freundin die sie schon länger kennt ihr
woran sie sie erkennt so nach dem motto
übrigens ich habe eine blaue schuhe oder
ich habe ein pinkes t shirt an so ich
dachte die zeit befreundet so habt ihr
schon vergessen wie er aussieht was ist
das für eine freundschaft wenn man nicht
weiß wieder andere aussieht aber
natürlich klassiker leute peinliche
momente die wir alle schon erlebt haben
du erkennst mich an meinem roten guten
schreibt man sich heute freund mein mann
hat ja vergessen wie die person aussieht
kann es ja keiner ahnen gesicht und dann
erblickt man von hinten eine person mit
einem roten hut die einen ganz anderen
kleidungsstil hat als die eigene
freundin die auch eine ganz andere
statur hat egal man trotzdem volle kanne
drauf am abend die personen und dann
einige momente erlebt da es ist nicht
die eigene freundin sondern einfach eine
random andere personen die in
nachhaltigen gleichen
überdimensionierten roten strohhut an
hat als wir das was man so alltäglich
auf deutschlands straßen sehen würde
oder den straßen der vereinigten staaten
glaube ich würde das gedrehte
mit dem nächsten ein kleiner
rausgekommen
sie sieht so etwas jetzt will die weise
wo seine frische idee gewesen der ja
echt also ohne schnee was für
geisteskranke menschen betreiben diesen
kanal leute ihr hattet eine aufgabe okay
das video heißt peinliche momente die
wir alle schon erlebt haben okay dafür
brauchen wir nicht viel
man braucht peinliche momente davon gibt
es genug im leben ist nicht so schwer
auf welche zu kommen und dann zieht ihr
eben alle ab die momente erlebt haben
okay da haben wir alle erlebt haben gibt
mir eine viertelstunde zeit ich kann
mich 20 peinliche momente die alle schon
erlebt haben aufzählen wir halten uns
das vorhaben heute es ist wirklich nicht
schön freund auf was kommen die leute
hinter 123 go der peinlichen moment den
wir alle schon erlebt haben indem wir
ließen mussten uns beim nächsten in die
rose geschah ja bist du es ein
peinlicher moment den wir alle schon
erlebt haben sind wir alle fucking
inkontinent auf dieser welt oder wie
können wir nicht unsere
körperflüssigkeiten und sonstige
substanzen im körper behalten scheinbar
in der welt von 12 lego nicht aber leute
ich hab auch ein video für euch lustige
schule hacks und ideen zu schulmaterial
gebt euch das was hier in diesem video
auftaucht das ist wirklich auch der
absolute oberhammer somit den menschen
die diesen kanal betreiben stimmt
irgendwas nicht dass es mittlerweile
sicher
also es geht darum folgendes problem hat
man ist müde in der schule man würde
gerne schlafen wollten was macht man
dann okay schule hektar also irgendeine
sache die man sonst nicht lenkt mit der
man sich den alltag leichter machen kann
hättest du auch gerne in der brille wie
diese für ihn wirklich langweiligen
unterricht druck ein großes bild von ihr
mit einer brille aus schneidet die
gläser aus der brille aus klebe diese
dann direkt auf deine echte brille ist
das jetzt eine schule heck gegen
müdigkeit im unterricht ich sollte ein
foto von einem eigenen gesicht
ausdrucken und meine augen ausschneiden
und dann eine brille tragen auf einmal
so ich habe vorher nie probleme gehabt
meiner sehstärke okay er trägt eine
brille weil dann soll ich meine eigenen
augen von innen auf die brille kleben ja
das ist der lustige schule der müdigkeit
im unterricht abnimmt cool das sieht
total nicht aus ich glaube zu der
echtheit des iboxx dieser brille müssen
wir mal eine experten befragen also es
wurde behauptet cool dass sie total echt
aus angela merkel was ist ihre meinung
dazu finden sie dass sie total echt aus
wenn du das nächste mal in einer echten
langweiligen klasse setzt schon kam die
augen aufhalten kann
egal was ist das was ist dass man gibt
es mal gewichtiger ich denke davon
alpträume was soll das das ist einfach
das ist ein psychothriller dieser kalt
das ist kein trendkanal das ist kein
wasser kanal
das ist ein psycho kanal was ist das für
ein gesicht selbst wenn es halbwegs
normal aussehen würde
okay es ist immer noch so dumme idee die
nicht funktioniert und ich weiß nicht
nochmal die im video packt er sophia
hast du so viel wissen von dämonen
besessen zu viel hat der satan besitz
von deiner seele ergriffen
möglicherweise also sollte ich da man
kann sagen wenn ein kanal der eigentlich
so jungen leuten punks und coole tipps
und live hacks zeigen soll eine den
eindruck gibt dass man gerade einen
psycho thriller anschaut dann läuft da
irgendwas schief national heute muss ich
aber auch sagen da ich doch noch ein
interesse daran habe meine geistige
gesundheit zu behalten und ich das
gefühl habe dass die so stetig schwindet
wenn ich diese videos schauer machen wir
in deutschland hat leute ich hab ich
hier drüben noch ein völlig
vorgeschlagen zu video verlinkt das war
es so weit von mir keine ahnung was sie
uns heute wieder angeschaut haben ich
könnt eure augen macht's gut